given G of X is equal to 8x Plus to find
G of 0 G of negative 5 and G of 2x plus
3 so all this is when they say G of X is
equal to 8x plus 2 this is a function
definition they're saying you give me
any X and you input it into my function
G and my function G will output we will
associate with that number X another
number that happens to be 8x plus 2 this
is one way to create an association it's
going to associate if you two put if you
were to put 1 here if this X is 1 you're
going to do 8 times 1 plus 2 so you
would associate 1 through G you would
associate 1 with 8 times 1 plus 2 which
is 10 so it's just another way of
creating Association that you could do
with sets of ordered pairs or you could
do it graphically but this is one of the
most typical ways that you'll see a
function defined it says look input an x
over here and I'm going to output 8x
plus 2 so with that out of the way let's
think about what the G of 0 is G of 0
literally just means we're inputting 0
into this function and this function
says whatever you're inputting I'm going
to output 8 times that plus 2 so G of 0
is going to be let me write it this way
so it becomes clear what I'm doing G of
0 is going to be 8 times 0 8 times 0 8
times 0 plus 2 plus plus 2 so wherever
we saw the X we replaced it what what it
with whatever we're inputting that is
our X in this situation right over here
and so this is equal to 8 times 0 plus 2
is just equal to 2 so G of 0 is equal to
2 let me just write that here Z of 0 is
equal to 2 now let's try G of negative 5
so let me write it this way G of alright
G of negative 5 is equal to and I'll try
to do the color-coding a little bit
better this time it's going to be equal
to 8 times our X which in this case is
negative 5 8 times negative 5 plus 2 8
times negative 5 plus 2 we're inputting
a queer
putting a negative 5 and we're going to
output 8 times negative 5 plus 2
wherever we saw the X we just replace it
with a negative 5 and this is just equal
to 8 times negative 5 is negative 40
plus 2 is equal to negative 38 so I'll
write this over here on the right we
have G of negative 5 is equal to
negative 38 now this last one is a
little bit interesting so we just did
this one now let's do G of G of 2x plus
3 so now they're not inputting a number
there in putting an expression and what
we have to do is everywhere where we see
X here we're going to replace it with
that expression if I did G of a circle
let me write this down if I did G of an
orange circle an orange circle right
over here by this function definition by
this function definition if I'm
inputting an orange circle
I should output an orange circle 8 times
the orange circle 8 times the orange
circle which doesn't make a lot of sense
but hopefully you get the idea that
whenever you're inputting you're just
going to multiply it times 8 and add 2
so if we input 2x + 3 we're going to
output this times 8 plus 2 wherever we
see an X we replace it with this right
over here so let's try that out so now
we have G of 2x + 3
G of 2x plus 3 is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to 8 times whatever
we're inputting 8 times whatever we're
inputting + 2 if we're inputting an
orange if this was an orange we'd put an
orange here if this is a negative 5 we
put a negative 5 you if this is a zero
we put a zero here in this case we're
inputting 2x plus 3 into our function so
we put 2 X plus 3 where the X is right
over there so 2x plus 3
whatever we input this function says
multiply it by 8 and add 2 we're
inputting 2x + 3 multiply it by 8 and
then add 2 and so this is going to be
equal to we just distribute the 8 we
just distribute the 8 and you get 16x
plus 24 and you still have this plus 2
out over here you still have this plus 2
out of
here so this is going to be equal to 16
X 16 X plus these two the add them up
you get 26 so we can write over here and
I'll do that same color so to be
consistent we have G of 2x plus 3 is
equal to 16x plus 26 and we're done I
know it's going to be confusing because
you're inputting you're replacing X with
something that has X in it but you
really should just view this as if this
was an orange ball or a star or even if
they said why isn't it wherever you see
an X you replace it with whatever you
are inputting it so what we were in
every instance we replace the X with 2x
plus 3